for years spacex has been more or less
dependent on nasa
and other commercial customers for
funding whether that be for research and
development
or rocket launches over the past year
though the financial situation of spacex
as well as elon musk has radically
changed elon musk's personal wealth
boomed from 24.6 billion
in april of 2020 to 151 billion dollars
in april of 2021.
meanwhile spacex was finally able to
complete their first
and second successful crude missions to
the iss which bolstered their reputation
amongst the private investor community
so where exactly did spacex get their
money from
today well starting off
let's take a look at the og customer for
spacex which is of course
nasa nasa has bought billions of dollars
worth of contracts over the past decade
from spacex
and at this point the number of
contracts nasa has made with spacex
is too many to go through individually
but we can't take a look at the most
significant contracts nasa has with
spacex
and how much total money nasa gives
spacex annually
first up we have the crew dragon this
project started off with nasa funding
research and development for a crude
capital
spacex and boeing had a bit of a fight
to see who would reach iss first
and last year spacex was able to claim
this title with demo 2.
demo 2 was just a demonstration mission
though as the name suggests
and the real crew dragon mission started
up in november of 2020 with the crew one
nasa has a total of six crew missions
planned and these are expected to
stretch out until the end of 2023
nasa expects to complete crew 2 and crew
3 by the end of this year
crew 4 and 5 are expected to be
completed next year
and crew 6 is expected to take place in
on the topic of iss missions spacex is
still working with nasa to complete
supplier runs to the iss
as well these missions are called crs
which stands for crew resupply
and spacex has a handful of these coming
up as well
they just completed crs-21 in december
of 2020.
looking forward they have crs 22 23
and 24 are scheduled for this year crs
and 26 are scheduled for 2022 by the
time all of the crew dragon
and crs missions are completed nasa
should have their own rocket space
launch system
up and running also they have several
crew launches scheduled with boeing
starling capsule
as long as they pass the orbital test
flight so i'm not quite sure if nasa
will contract spacex for iss missions
again nasa is trying to make a return to
the moon within the next couple of years
and so the iss is not their focus right
now
we may see another set of iss crew
dragon and crs missions
but i'm not sure if nasa will take it
much further than that
this doesn't mean that nasa is done with
spacex though nasa does have a variety
of other contracts with spacex like the
lunar starship
in may of 2020 nasa awarded spacex 135
million dollars
to modify starship into a crude lunar
lander spacex will likely also continue
to launch various satellites and
complete smaller missions for nasa
but how much money does spacex actually
receive from nasa
at the end of the day well since nasa is
a government organization
we get a full breakdown of how exactly
they spend their money every quarter
if you go onto usaspending.gov you can
delve into each government organization
and see a breakdown of their budget
every quarter taking a look back at the
fiscal year of 2020
you'll see that the top organization
nasa's funding is not even a space
company
rather the highest percentage of nasa's
funding goes to the california institute
of technology
this was followed up by lockheed martin
who received a total of 2.8 billion
dollars
and jacobs technology who received a
little over 1 billion dollars
after this we have boeing who received
897 million dollars
and spacex comes in at fifth place
receiving 869 million dollars
shifting over to the fiscal year of 2021
we'll see a very similar breakdown in
terms of funding
however spacex is receiving a slightly
larger proportion of the funding
this year so far in 2021 spacex has
received 4.74
of nasa's total funding last year they
only received 3.44
of the total funding this may be skewed
as we're still relatively early in the
year
so we'll estimate in the middle and call
it four percent of nasa's total funding
by the end of this year
considering that nasa's annual budget is
about 25 billion dollars
this gives spacex right about 1 billion
dollars
anyways another major customer for
spacex is also a government organization
which is of course the us department of
defense now
the budget breakdown for the department
of defense is more secretive for obvious
reasons
they do give a breakdown as to what
categories they spend the money in
however they don't specify where exactly
the money is spent in each category
for example spacex falls under the air
force based procurement category
but if we navigate to this page on
usaspending.gov
we really don't get much information we
see that they have spent 544 million
dollars on acquisition of assets
and 70 million on contractual services
and supplies
but that's really all we get if we do a
bit more digging and searching for his
basics specifically though
we are able to find an ongoing contract
that spacex has with the department of
defense
this contract started in march of 2018
and is expected to end in september of
so about three and a half years the
total potential award for spacex is
445.1 million dollars
out of which 251.4 million dollars has
already been paid out
spacex does still have about 200 million
worth of potential payouts
but given that the majority of the
contract time has already passed
i'm not sure if they'll end up maxing
out their award amount so
will base their annual revenue from the
air force on the amount they have
already received
if we spread 251.4 million over three
years
we get approximately 83.8 million
dollars per year from the dod
moving on we have commercial customers
that aren't u.s government organizations
like siriusxm radio
at the end of 2020 siriusxm worked with
spacex to launch a satellite for their
radio services
similarly the korean army worked with
spacex in july of 2020
and we also saw a few writers with
planet labs but commercial customers
that aren't us government organizations
are by far the minority we might see
four or five such launches
every year we'll call it four per year
to account for any rideshare missions
that only bring in partial revenue
spacex charges 15 million dollars per
used falcon 9 launch
with four commercial launches per year
this brings in approximately 200 million
dollars for spacex annually
that covers basically all the contracts
and commercial launches spacex conducts
every year
next up we have funding from investor
funding rounds
many people think that since spacex is a
private company that they don't have
investors
but this is actually not true spacex
does have investors
in fact they have a lot of investors if
you're an accredited investor
which basically means that you have over
1 million assets not including the house
you live in
then you can invest in spacex and other
private companies too
spacex generally conducts two
fundraising rounds every year
in 2020 this included a round in march
and around in august
the rounded march raised 221 million
dollars
and the round in august raised a total
of 1.9 billion dollars
just two months ago spacex raised
another 850 million dollars
but that would count as 2021. so it
seems like spacex is raising about 2
billion
every year at this point that covers all
the main sources of funding for spacex
today
but we do have a few more smaller
sources here and there like the dear
moon project
a japanese billionaire is funding a
private starship trip around the moon
for himself and a couple of artists
called the dear moon project
the mission is expected to last 6 days
and accommodate for 10-12 people
we don't know how much a trip is going
to cost but it's likely in hundreds of
millions
similarly universal pictures is trying
to work with spacex to film a movie in
space starring tom cruise
as spacex continues to build the
reliability and safety of their rockets
such major projects will likely only
increase in frequency
to account for such projects as well as
other miscellaneous sources of revenue
we'll add another 200 million dollars
onto spacex's annual funding
this adds up to a total of 3.48 billion
dollars in funding for spacex
every year in terms of a breakdown about
28.7
of spacex's funding comes from nasa 2.4
percent comes from the air force
5.7 comes from other commercial
customers and
another 5.7 percent comes from major
projects as well as miscellaneous
sources
finally the last 57.5 percent comes from
the private investors of spacex
as you can see the majority of the
funding for spacex today
actually comes from private investors as
opposed to the government
if we add up the non-government portions
and the government portions
we'll see that 68.9 of spacex's funding
comes from private sources
and only 31.3 of spacex's funding comes
from the government
this is obviously a radical shift from
several years ago where most of spacex's
funding came from government contracts
but who even are these private investors
well
though individual accredited investors
can't participate in funding rounds and
purchase taken spacex
the vast majority of private investors
in spacex today are institutional
investors like hedge funds and
other companies this includes companies
like sakia capital
google fidelity bank of america and
bailey gifford
looking forward the contributions from
the private investor industry will
likely
only grow something else to consider is
that spacex themselves will start to
generate large amounts of profit with
starlink and commercial starship trips
i didn't include these ventures in
today's calculations as they're both
still very early stage projects with
little to no revenue
however with time these projects will
likely start to generate funding for
spacex
as well elon musk does not want to take
spacex public till they have established
consistent travel to mars
so we probably won't see an ipo anytime
soon
we may see an ipo of the starling
portion of the business though
which will get the public involved with
spacex as well
and finally as tesla continues to grow
and stabilize
elon musk will likely start to liquidate
his tesla stake to fund a potential
martian city or base or something like
that
at the end of the day spacex used to be
heavily dependent on nasa
and the government but as they have
proven their ability to innovate and
advance
we have seen more and more private
interest and today
private investment actually counts for
the majority of spacex's funding
did you guys realize that comment that
down below also
drop a like if you guys would love to
invest in spacex and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys
on the next one